[Music]
I bought a little piece of a pickleball
team oh really Miami pickleball how much
how much did I how much did it cost uh
yeah
I don't really want to say that it's
kind of a crazy question how much of the
team did I buy you're always asking
people net worth and [__] up no I'm not
you're like if I ever said that market
what kind of Revenue are they doing
yeah but that's for that's for a company
that's fair all right you're a company I
don't think I bought I mean you're a
brand dude yeah how much is the brand
Cody Co you would believe it out how
much you pay for your pickleball six
million dollars okay I'm kidding I'm
kidding 17 million yeah so cool
um I'm not gonna say but
I mean it was in the thousands of
dollars that's yeah that wasn't anything
crazy yeah they like bought
I mean how much do they spend on this
team 2.5 million
that's it really on the whole on the
whole team
they were bad I guess drop in the Hat
dude that's pretty crazy Who convinced
you how to buy pickleball team the fact
that it's a six board probably yeah it's
the fastest growing sport in America I'm
pretty sure and the team is owned by
like Nick curios and
um a bunch of other like celebrity
investors are they good
I don't know their merch looks sick oh
my God oh my God you know what I just
looks sick I'm gonna find the unsung
heroes of pickleball you know it's like
it really matters are they good what do
you mean I mean in a sport that's like
this new and this kind of like quickly
growing you kind of just want to get in
on the ground floor if it
if it who put you on
uh the guys that live in Miami like
Steven and nice Cameo guys that's not
even that new
pickleball I think the league is
but like any like if you were if you
were to own any NBA team like near the
beginning like that would have made you
money yeah
it's true but he just compared
pickleball to NBA not that and yeah you
laugh now Ryan wait 40 [__] years
dude you don't think wait 100.
absolutely why not it's sick it's not
even gonna be as big as tennis it's so
fun it's a game
you know how [__] stupid golf is yeah
also a game and the biggest what do you
mean it's huge golf is [__] look up
what's like the the uh I know I'd be
remiss if I didn't point out the best
pickleball podcast on the internet right
now
which is pissed and pickled oh my God
hosted by none other than Hunter's
mother what is this real oh yeah yeah
piston pickled look it up
did she play
her and her
um co-host they play and they do a
podcast about pickles oh yeah Missy
oh my God I love this let's get our
co-host's name as well
Missy and Lori what did they only talk
about pickleball yeah it's their thing
see this is what I mean people love this
[__] Ryan
you're Ryan you're crazy if you think
this is not going to be as big as NBA
we got people building courts in their
backyard you know hey I passed about it
already no no stop to stop this everyone
shut the [__] up right now
it's my birthday
um no
two things here one
why doesn't oh nice nice nice Sophie
nice nice this is your Wednesday cake
this is our Wednesday
candles
why don't we take out last week how many
teams are in this league
can TMG sponsor a team
uh yeah I'm sure we could yeah why don't
we get in on a team
piston pickled
they become an exclusive reporter on one
of these teams they do a five minute
segment every week
America's fastest growing support in
2023 is pickleball
I think they said that about Bitcoin too
which by the way is up ten percent yeah
I know I know it's back it's back it's
[__] back baby yeah in a big way yeah
you're hoping no
no portfolio is finally in the black
again oh so you've made it after
like I mean I first bought Bitcoin what
how many years have we even [__]
talking about this too long doesn't
matter
yeah all of them it's true
there are currently 36.5 million
pickleball players
Ryan how many people played basketball
in the world
yeah by the way I'm kind of kidding I
don't think it's going to be as big as
the NBA but but it is huge like it is
going to be big it is going to be big
yeah like tennis golf all these random
games that
became people's lives people are
obsessed with pickleball I guess it like
defines
old people's lives it's more because
viewership though like
you have to be able to get people to
watch it like like a lot of people Dive
Right but how many people are sitting
down to watch the diving yeah but how is
this any day man hey tennis hey I'm
gonna go ahead and buy a shoveling yeah
yeah dig up your grave right there I do
believe Ryan is just [__] buried you
I do believe Ryan has just carved out a
space in the Earth for you just a little
bit I don't think he did he just named
an Olympic sport no but it was just the
way but I also know that
I I never I never thought diving
like there was a pickleball oh
pickleball slam averages 670 000 viewers
suck on that ninja that's crazy
that's [__] huge
I watched the CBS where all the
celebrities played pickleball on CBS
like a couple months ago it was not
great it was just like look up how many
people tuned into F1 every weekend
f1's pretty Niche it's a big niche
it's just like all of Europe or whatever
but they don't count also by the way I
think a good 1.54 billion average 70
dude that's insane 70 million people
watch that [__] every [__] weekend
losers man but I think also a good
litmus test for something like this at a
a game that people actually watch is
have you played it
because if you have you know it's
instantly addicting it's like it is it's
it's like just you just want to play
more
so that to me is that combined with the
fact that it's growing so fast makes me
think that like I like watching golf
because I play it I know how [__]
hard it is yeah so that to me is kind of
like pickleball
but then again there are tons of sports
like Ping Pong that I feel the same way
about that don't get a lot of viewership
so I mean maybe we go all in on a
pickleball podcast bro why don't we get
a pickleball team but we have to draft
to athletic [__] yeah okay like
former D1 like tennis players that
didn't quite go pro in tennis and
they're like
this sounds kind of stupid and we say
the all of our subscribers here are
going to pay you a crazy ass salary to
go through and clean up and dominate The
League so we would be like Brad Pitt in
Hardball or Moneyball or whatever yeah
no we'd be like we want to be the
Yankees of
yeah of pickleball like we come in we
change the game yeah because we recruit
differently
we got the money we're the money guys
yeah
TMG the money guys yeah and we leverage
all of our years of content creation to
uh develop the most insane pickleball
Duo and you know what's crazy about our
pickleball team we have a third
yeah we have a backup yeah yeah okay so
if one of our guys gets injured because
he's playing so goddamn [__] hard
they're like how
are we supposed to compete with that I
think that's probably pretty standard
then we have a bigger bench yeah yeah
yeah we have a we have a third string
how about that okay yeah
I guess we should do Cody and we'll do
pickleball we should we should do that
now you're talking yeah
we should do coding will do and I'll
make the whole thing a plug for the
Miami pickle Club
dude
we can go to Miami in Miami yeah yeah do
it with the team yeah
and we bring Missy and Lori to
commentate our game
yeah
and then hunters in the background like
no the pickleball craze is real but it's
TV potential is a different story media
wait
they're talking about us media
Executives oh oh everyone shut up and
pickleball stakeholders share the
challenges ahead as the growing sport
now that's that's me both of those are
me
media Executives I'm listening support
now aims to become a sustainable media
and streaming product
Ryan Fawcett of TMG Studios thinks it
will not whoa that's Ryan Fawcett on
paper wrote this sport is going [__]
Ryan Lawson formerly of TMG Studios
aggressively slandered the Miami
pickleball team stating this is the
dumbest sport I've seen in my entire
media career and it's going nowhere
followed by many slurs whoa
[Laughter]
yeah I don't know if you know this
people Ryan's a slur guy I'm not
a record show I am not